if you start digging into the occult
you're opening a door and you might not
be strong enough to close it and then
you have to call me someone wrote Into
My Show said Michael if you could meet
the devil at him twice
personally
now that girl
not well the first time
[Music]
baudelaire said the finest trick the
devil ever played is to convince you
that he does not exist
in recent days however
he's been kind of flamboyant wouldn't
you say he's being a little more Brazen
about his existence when you look at
devil costumes at the Grammys when you
look at all sorts of weird Wiccan occult
rituals and some of the biggest stages
on Earth and yet some people still don't
believe it we are joined today very
fortunately by father Dan rehill not
only a Catholic priest but the Exorcist
here in Nashville I am thank you Michael
thank you for joining good to be here
people tend to like the political
commentary that focuses on the
day-by-day policy and then the culture
and then even sometimes the spiritual
stuff that underpins it the most
pushback I ever get is when I mention
demons when I mention things like the
devil people stop me they say Michael
now you're getting Fantastical now
you're getting crazy you're talking
about things that don't exist
but these things do exist they do I mean
if you're
you're a Christian any Christian and you
follow the scriptures we know there was
a war in heaven and Lucifer the most
brilliant and the most beautiful the
angels rebelled
because of the plan for
the Sun the word to become flesh and he
was horrified that God would lower
himself to our nature and so he said I
will not serve and he was cast out with
his minions and they became the Fallen
Angels the demons and they were cast
down to earth
and
soon thereafter Eve encountered The
Serpent and that was the beginning of
our demise and so this is not
um mythical this is fact
the Devil is a real person a person in
the sense of having a will and an
intellect
um he's a spirit but he's a person and
what you said is true that he used to be
very hidden and he used to be very
subtle
and it should worry people that he's
suddenly not worried about being seen
because that means
it's what most
people would deduct from that is that he
realizes that his Reign is coming to a
close and he's using everything he has
now to try to drag as many people down
with him so we can be miserable in hell
too yeah what do you say to people
who
say that's a nice story father but I
don't believe that the Bible is anything
more than a collection of stories that
have influenced the culture I don't
believe there was any such thing as
Satan falling from Heaven I don't
believe in Adam and Eve I don't believe
anyone bit the Apple I don't believe in
original sin I don't believe in the
personification of evil I don't believe
in evil period I think we're basically
just a bunch of meat sacks and all of
our conceptions of these things are just
chemicals firing off in our brain and
you can't convince me otherwise
oh well yeah you're a non-believer so
good luck
but that's it if you don't believe I I
can't make you believe but that's your
decision
and I would say you better really dig
into what you believe a little more
deeper before you make your final
decision because think about the
consequences if you're right
no harm at the end of life if you're
wrong
you spend eternity separated from God
that would be a lot to risk
so just on basic common sense it would
be good to like do your research a
little deeper before you come to
conclusion like I don't because I would
say you don't believe but do you really
understand have you done any
investigation into this have you read
have you researched have you looked
at first of all there's so many miracles
in the church just the Eucharistic
Miracles they baffle NASA they can't
figure out how they were done and by for
for people who are not so Catholic a
Eucharistic Miracle the Eucharistic
Miracle would be what in the course of a
mass when the body and blood of Jesus is
transfigured from Bread and Wine
now during the mass we can't see that
but we believe it
but on occasion to bolster the faith of
of the Catholic Community the Lord will
actually allow the appearance and the um
accidents you would call them to be
changed into the body blood as well
which means the host starts bleeding and
dripping human blood male blood
from a man of Middle Eastern descent
and the host becomes the flesh the
cardiac muscle of of a heart that's been
horribly beaten and assaulted and still
has white blood cells even weeks after
it's being tested
that's not explainable so you'd have to
say how has that happened that's the
good side but on the bad side if if you
were an exorcist and you watched someone
levitate off a couch
and I can't put that into the DSM manual
classification of a psychological
disorder you'd have to say something's
happening here there might be something
beyond what I believe
so I would say maybe do your research a
little more before you come to that
conclusion have you ever seen anyone
levitate off I have
go on
well it's an interesting thing because
in the Catholic church in America so the
USCCB that's our governing body of
Bishops we're the only body of Bishops
that require before we do the right of
exorcism the person has to have both a
physical checkup and a psychological
exam uh psychological exams are
expensive they're about two thousand
dollars so and we don't charge the
victim because they're already suffering
and they often don't have the resources
they've lost their home their job
usually their wife husband
but we require that because the law says
that I have to have
um moral certitude that the devil is
present and to do that we have to rule
out psychological problems and all this
okay when I saw the man levitate off the
couch
I had moral certitude yeah that that's
not a psychological condition
in in in all
uh countries The Exorcist needs moral
certitude to perform an exorcism that
there is the presence of the demon
um but like I said in America we have to
do those two tests to rule out other
things
um so when I saw this young man levitate
off the couch
well there's my moral certitude that
this is not a psychological problem
because
that that kind of that can't force
someone to come out of the chair on
their own uh so that that was when I
didn't have to do that
the exam so
I I believe all of this I none of this
surprises me my view of the world is a
Catholic view of the world
for people who might
be skeptical it is it possible you just
misperceived what was going on or was
your mind playing tricks on you or
no
period
and I'll tell you why
um I don't work alone I mean that would
be
horribly imprudent to go into a
situation when you're dealing with
demons or the Devil Himself alone so
contrary to popular opinion and the
movies we see about exisms we never go
alone at midnight during a thunderstorm
to a strange person's house in the woods
to do an exorcism you know sort of like
this
with this is not the usual setting of
okay better so I have a team I always
have other people with me often it's
another priest so we're all seeing the
same thing you know
um they can speak languages that they've
never known they know things about you
or other people in the room that they
couldn't know so these are the Hallmarks
of how we would determine is this really
a demon Supernatural knowledge of things
they could not know languages they could
they have not learned that they can
speak fluently and and superhuman
strength
I remember there was a little
um nun about a hundred pounds five foot
um I won't mention the order and um when
she was going through a Deliverance it
took six large Men My Size to hold her
down
and that's that's what I mean it's it's
not possible that that little girl could
have that strength so we look at these
things as kind of the Hallmarks of this
is not normal this is a supernatural
thing I've seen that same nun run up a
20-foot wall like a squirrel
and two thousand people at a conference
saw it too
so
there's the proof that that's not right
can you can we all agree that's not
normal that's not normal that's not
normal I've never seen that happen no
and it's scary when you see it because
he likes to inflame fear in people's
hearts
when people or I guess demons or
speaking this language in having
possessed these people
I'm assuming they're not speaking
Swedish you know what what languages no
they typically pick up ancient languages
or Hebrew or Aramaic or even Greek and I
don't speak those for the most part so
it normally has to be recorded but you
can tell right away you know oh I know
that that's definitely
Hebrew or that's this and I'm like has
this person ever studied these languages
no No in fact sometimes they're you know
maybe young maybe 15 16 year old who
hasn't even gone through high school and
then or they can tell you things about
yourself
so we always go to confession before we
go into a Deliverance because you never
want them to not that we're sinning you
know in these great ways but you want no
weapon
leveraged against you you know you bring
up confession and I had this experience
it's taken me 32 years to figure out
something that's probably pretty basic
to confession and confession is
Sacrament where Catholics go into the
box like you see in the movies confess
your sins on your knees before the
priest and the priest says Volvo and you
go out and I was an atheist for 10 years
I reverted in my early 20s and only
recently
I was walking out of confession and I I
had this thought which is not only do I
feel spiritually at peace here but
what's so striking is that I feel
physically different so it's I could
understand feeling spiritual late pieces
maybe there's just some psychological
thing happening when I say these sins to
the priest but
I would go into the confessional and I
would feel racked by whatever wrath lust
gluttony you go down the list and it
would I'd be shaking almost
I walk out of the confessional that
physical
feeling is gone and I said how do you
explain that if if confession is not
what it says it is
well it is but even people who would
agree what it is don't realize like as
human beings we're spiritual
persons incarnate in a body right and
that's a that's one person together so
what affects the spirit is going to
affect the body what affects the body
affects the spirit and when we amass
sins particularly if they're grave sins
over a long period of time in particular
there are demons that hook into us and
they harass us and they follow each
other in packs and
so often specifically it's like a
snowball going down a hill I just did
this and then I did that and then I went
to this sin and then all of a sudden
here I am and I'm
in a bad place
that's what they're doing they're
they're
pushing you to keep going further into
your sinfulness and when the priest
absolves the the person in the
confessional not only is their soul
wiped clean but the demons are broken
off the person
and so when you feel that
levity that lightness of leaving the
confessional so many people say to me I
feel like a weight's off my back yeah
because you've been set free it's not
just the sin it's the demons attached to
the sin I used to think
that the type of scene you just
described
was merely a helpful metaphor for what
goes on in our moral lives
it's a nice picture ah yes it's the you
know I mean everybody perfectly secular
people will say so and so had demons oh
he never got over his demons but they
mean it in this metaphorical sense they
do and
the longer I've lived
the more literally I view that kind of a
scene and even more so the less of a
distinction I see between the literal
and the figurative yeah well we also
believe we have an angel
assigned to us a guardian angel
that angel has a a lot of power but the
more you acknowledge the angel and ask
for his help the more power he can give
you so I tell people every morning wake
up thank God for the new day thank song
gratitude and then turn to your angel
and say I appreciate your help today and
these are the things I struggle with
these are the appointments today I think
going to be difficult the meetings I
have can you be there and intercede for
me through these things
you'd be surprised how different your
day goes and if you surrender to the day
and not push for getting things your way
because we frequently think I have to
have it this way but then if you let it
go and see what God's going to do if
you've given him permission over the day
he will wrap it up in a way so much more
clean need and tidy than you could ever
imagine that you could do
but these These are these are but you
have to do it to test it right so some
people say I don't believe in that I'm
not going to do it well then you're
going to miss out we can only lead you
to the water
so you have your angel but then you have
these demons now the demons
their number one job is to get you to
sin
when most people talk about demons they
think of The Exorcist movie
um the Devil with the horns and the
spear
he can appear that way but 90
six seven percent of his work is to
tempt to sin and all of his minions
because when we sin we break away from
God and once we break away from God then
they can really go after us like it's
like stepping is a Pit Bull with a five
foot chain it's like stepping in to the
three foot Mark you're suddenly now in
the zone right then they can really
attack you so if they can get you to sin
then they can really have a field day
and really ruin your life
coming after you physically like the
supernatural effects of the devil I call
the first but then the sin is the
natural the targeting somebody through
vexations or obsessions or oppressions
or possession would be ways that we
would say is the supernatural power of
the devil to inflict harm on somebody
what is the distinction between all of
those tricks Okay so
vexation with sort of an infestation is
normally things that happen in
somebody's home or in their space it
could it doesn't have to be the home it
could be the office wherever the car
where the devil can
manipulate move things create chaos
losing losing car keys constantly the
computer constantly whenever I try to
print a homily
it only jams for the homily or it only
jams when I'm printing out a prayer that
would be like I'm like oh yeah so I have
to take authority over that Spirit of
blockage and then it just goes right
through
um
but they can be bad like the Amityville
Horror would be the worst example of a
vexation of a home
um and then you you have the person
himself so an obsession a spirit of
obsession attacks the mind
and people who have this sort of attack
it's the most horrible attack they can't
think they have voices screaming at them
all day screaming blasphemies putting
horrible thoughts in their head visions
of suicide and they can't sleep so then
they're even more in a bad way they
often will wind up in a mental hospital
but they're not it's not a mental
problem it's a demon problem
um and then oppression
is attached to the body
that could be through sickness or in the
worst cases I've seen
um you know somebody who lives alone
wakes up with bite marks all over the
body you've seen that yeah
could it be uh no you can't even finish
you can't bite your own back
right yeah I've not seen a dog it
couldn't be a no no no dog didn't sneak
in in the morning lock the door when he
left no
um or scratch marks
or
you know in the worst cases
you see people who will vomit things
that are odd like frogs or nails
I've only seen that in when I went to
exism school I haven't seen it first
firsthand but this is all possible in
the realm of evil because they they can
imitate the power of God but they it's
short-lived and it's not as powerful
then if this things escalate and they
kind of meld together it would lead to a
full-on possession where the demon
usually Satan himself will take
possession of the body
this isn't people think they they take
the soul you can't take the soul
you can't sell your soul you know why
you can't sell yourself
you don't own it
you can't sell what you don't own but
he'll trick you into thinking that and
then that puts the person in despair so
so Robert Johnson is there at the delta
in Mississippi he wants to be the best
blues guitarist ever and he sells a soul
to the devil at least that's what some
album executive said decades later he
can't really sell a soul
so there instead it's just the person
inviting the devil in to their body yep
okay yeah when you make a deal
with the devil it's an invitation and he
takes the invitation very seriously he
comes right in
um one of the worst cases I've ever
heard was from The Exodus of New York
City back about 15 years ago
um
he was telling me well it would have
been longer than that maybe 20 25.
um
there was a woman a young girl Juilliard
a violinist and she was about to
graduate she was brilliantly talented
but all of her friends were getting job
offers and she had none and her friends
remember always hearing her say the
words I would do anything to be famous
well guess who's listening
your angels listening but also there's
other things in the room and it wasn't
long after that that she went to bed one
night had a dream
and she said in the dream was the most
beautiful man she'd ever seen naked
another sign calling card of the devil
uh and he said do you really want fame
and power and she said I do and he
produced a contract
and he took his finger and slashed her
finger and had her sign in her blood
and then he touched the contract and it
burst into flames and the ashes fell on
the floor
so pretty easy to understand what
happened right you don't need an
advanced literary right
so when you wake up from that dream and
you remember it you might
take a pause and be like I don't think
that was a good thing but what's worse
is her finger was cut and the ashes were
next to the boat
so
she still doesn't say anything
not to be the Devil's Advocate but I
guess to be the devil's advocate
could this girl just have been nuts
making it up or just
she could have been she could have yeah
but you have to hear the whole story
okay So within a couple of weeks she
signs this multi-national tour
makes a ton of money becomes very
popular and famous on this circuit and
within a few years she gets involved
with drugs goes to Needles gets HIV now
she's dying in a New York Hospital
and this whole thing comes back to how
this started and she calls her Filipino
mother
and tells her the story
and mommy calls the Chancery hysterical
I need a Nexus right away from my
daughter
so Jim is the exit he shows up and they
tell him the whole story from the dream
forward and he says okay well that's not
good you signed a blood Covenant with
the Devil
so I'm going to need you to
break that with the blood Covenant so
you're going to write out the whole
Creed and then you're going to sign in
your blood
well the doctor's like she has AIDS
she's not signing anything in blood not
going to happen and he says well then
you need to step out of the room because
she needs to do this
and she did do it and she signed the
contract the Creed and um within a few
seconds agreed for those who don't know
us I believe in God what we believe is
as our faith yeah the whole faith in a
neat little package
and she signs it
and she convulses and flat lines and
dies
so now the doctor comes back and he's
really upset the mother is out of her
mind they're all blaming the priest
hysteria goes on for about 10 minutes
and then all of a sudden she jumps up
off the table
oh
she's back
oh and they test her
no HIV no AIDS she's completely healed
and so she then committed for the rest
of her life to only
do music that would honor God and to
tell people about the reality of the
devil and not to make deals with them
what's so crazy about the story is there
are so many stories that are I had not
heard that that story
I don't I'm trying to think even if I
was reading some of you know your
writing and but
wow
hearing that
I'm
struck but then I think well there are
all these Miracles that have happened
throughout history and then what
hits me is
how do people not believe in the face of
all of this well even I was just at a
conference on signs and wonders
I was thinking of all these little
coincidences these improbable perhaps
naturally impossible things that
everybody has experienced at some point
in his or her life yeah and when they
strike you you're so hit by them and
then five seconds later you just go on
with your life and you it's as though
they never happened yeah so then I'm
actually less surprised that people
could hear a story like that and and not
believe yeah I think a third of the
people
if you picked up a mountain and moved it
over there a third of the people believe
right away a third of the people will
say it never happened it was always over
there and the third and they'll be
confused and I think that's just the way
human nature pans out I've been pretty
blessed in my life I've seen so many
miracles I mean so many that I expect
them now
I used to be a contemplative hermit just
praying with the woods with a group of
Hermits for the most of the day and when
during that time
the Lord one day said to me he said the
days are fast approaching
when the extraordinary will seem
ordinary
the extraordinary will seem ordinary
meaning like the miraculous will be so
prevalent for what I'm going to do that
it will start to seem ordinary
but don't ever take it ordinary because
it's all Grace and you have to always
acknowledge it this is a great gift
and um
they're just so many I mean even the
smallest little things like there's a
nun I'm friends with in manjugoria this
place in Bosnia
she
the beautiful Community called the
community the Beatitudes I think they
have a chapter in Denver and they were
in charge of providing dessert for an
orphanage it was like 250 kids coming
for a barbecue picnic thing and the nuns
were doing the dessert and so one night
she put in charge of the dessert
got a sample pack of like 12 pudding
cups said will this be okay
and she says oh yes wonderful make sure
we have enough
and the nun who was purchasing them got
the day wrong
and she thought the barbecue was going
to be the following day and they hadn't
arrived when the kids showed up and she
said we have a big problem because you
know I don't have the pudding cups
she's like well they we have all the
other food I mean they're going to eat
but put out the 12-pack at the end of
the table
and she goes well that's going to be
terrible like only 12 kids will get all
the other kids will feel better she goes
just put it out
she puts it out
in all 250 kids go through and every kid
has a pudding cup
and she looks at me and she says you
know what the best part of this is
he didn't just multiply the food he
multiplied the plastic cups
and I go sister why is that a good thing
she goes because we kept them we have
evidence of this miracle
yeah what people hear these Miracles and
and they'll sort of laugh or write it
off or just dismiss them including
Christians and I sometimes wonder say
hold on you believe that God the son
became incarnate and walked around and
performed public Miracles and then was
crucified and died and was buried and on
the third day rose again from the dead
and sojourned on Earth again for 40 days
performing so many miracles that Saint
John could not possibly record them all
because all those books would fill up
more than the entirety of the Earth but
you don't believe that your car keys
could have turned up in an improbable
place you don't believe that God could
multiply some pudding cups I think
where does the leap of faith jump in
here it seems they've already accepted
quite a lot I don't know I feel it's the
Newbie attitude
blessed are the unbelievers they will
not be disappointed
because part of believing is impactful
on seeing the miracle experiencing the
miracle bringing forth the miracle Jesus
could do very little in his hometown not
because he couldn't do it because he's
Bound by his own rules of Providence
and so he is required that Faith be part
of him doing the Miracles
so if you're not going to believe you're
not going to see them unless you know he
has an incredible man of
love for you to the point of like Saul
of Tarsus where he's going to force you
to see yeah
I mean sometimes they'll do it when I
was reverting after 10 years of
debauchery and decadence and
atheism practical if not explicit
I did
I had a lot of these experiences it was
a lot it was a fairly lengthy
intellectual process of coming to accept
that God exists and then coming to
accept that Christ is who he says he is
I'm coming to accept that the church is
what she says she is and sort of around
that point that I started to have these
numinous experiences and I thought at
the time
this probably doesn't speak very well of
my condition right now that God feels
the need to grab me by my shoulders
shake me or smack me in the face and say
stupid I'm here yeah you know but how
great that he did right right because
where would we both of us be yeah same
thing for me yeah you you were not a
lifelong believing practicing Catholic
no I left the church for 20 years
so you leave the church and you were I
read a banker in New York
that seems like I don't want to besmirch
all Bankers but I just knowing friends
who have worked in that profession that
can be a very different lifestyle not
always conducive to Virtue no
particularly
on Wall Street around from Harry's right
right now yeah
um yeah that's a life style it's full of
drugs and money and power and all the
decadencies that go with it you know I I
watch guys cash checks for 150 000 and
spent it that weekend
rent The Penthouse of the plaza bring in
all the
ladies and the booze and the drugs and
just do it all over on Monday like
that's a Life Style
so with that comes with his great sin
you're going to have a lot of demons
that are just hovering pushing you to go
further
but not everybody's like that in fact in
the center of that whole Community is
little Our Lady of Victory Church yeah
and they had a group there that they
founded called The Wall Street young
Catholics Association
so when I had my conversion I had to
dump a bunch of people in my life that
weren't healthy and I said I gotta find
some good people here so I joined the
young Wall Street that's where I met
father Jim labar The Exorcist
um so there's good people there not
everybody's involved in all this stuff
but it's if you're young
um and susceptible to all that it's all
there for the taking and you mentioned
earlier these young people like this
case of this violinist woman who say I
would do anything for fame I would do
anything and I you all these young and
hungry people who are very ambitious I
can't help but notice there's a lot of
occult and demonic symbolism
specifically in Hollywood and we focus
on it now because Sam Smith gets up at
the Grammys dressed up like the devil
and jiggles around about cheating on
your wife and uh I don't know Lady Gaga
doing weird performances and all sorts
of things
but this has been the case in Hollywood
Forever well I would go back further
Jesus said the prince of this world the
rule of this world is Satan right but it
seems especially pronounced in Hollywood
well no no you're right but now he has
vehicles to promote that he didn't have
back then
so I mean think about this that
violinist that was pre-social media
now think about all the people on social
media on Instagram that just want to be
loved and they they put all this stuff
out there why so that you'll like them
it's all about Envy Instagram is just
about Envy and in the end I suppose
gluttony in that they call it a feed
like you're scrolling through your feed
satiate your appetite for pixels yeah
yeah and in Twitter it's that's all
about anger
yeah and Facebook is they just sell you
so they're all involved in one of these
sort of capital sins and how that draws
people in Imagine if you're spending
your whole day trying to make the world
love you and you're taking your own
photo all day and photoshopping it and
putting in fancy backgrounds and then
posting it saying look at me look at me
look at me
I mean that's that's narcissist right
there you don't have the pool to fall in
but you're you're already in
and those people are trapped because
that that doesn't end after one post
then they have to do one tomorrow yeah
and this is a whole life is all about
them
yeah I can't help but notice so opposite
of the Gospel I have a lot of friends
from Hollywood a lot of friends in Show
Business
and a lot of people I know in that
industry and in Hollywood in particular
do not turn out very well you you
especially think about child actors
almost all of whom go completely off the
rails but
maybe most actors that I know
have terrible lives
I don't just mean because they don't
make any money like most actors don't
make any money I mean their personal
lives are just get wrecked and more so
than my friends who are in other
Industries
well again think about what they do all
day so the focus of their life is on
them and being in front of a screen and
then on a big screen where everybody
could clap and tell you how great you
are and everybody around you probably to
not get pushed off the team is telling
you what you want to hear
and your life is so focused on you think
about all the marriages like it's a joke
people say if you last 10 years in
Hollywood that's like you're 75 years in
real life because it's and then you
spend half your year away from each
other
filming love scenes with other women how
on Earth is that going to work in a
beautiful tropical island
with alcohol yeah
but it but it'll work and essentially
summer camp because film sets are it's
like summer camp I mean it's this whole
group of new people it's a very intense
experience you're there forever so you
can see how that can go off the rails
and speaking of the screens and all the
social media and demons
have you heard about the AI demon I have
the story for those who haven't heard it
before is
an AI engineer or artist was
experimenting and
plugged in said give me a picture of
Marlon Brando and a picture of Brando
pops up and and this person was trying
to explore the breadth of the map that
AI is processing so I said okay show me
the opposite of this who shows a
landscape or something say okay show me
the opposite of that so you think okay
maybe that shows you Rando again right
the opposite of the opposite but it
doesn't it shows this This Woman's
withered old hag
that this artist calls it lowab and then
the artist inputs generated pictures of
Heaven you know Angelic wires and
worshiping God and inputs that
juxtaposes it with the loab this demon
looking lady
and what the AI spits out the most
gruesome images
snuff sexual abuse violence all this
almost as if
you presented an image of Heaven to a
demon yeah maybe the craziest part of it
is
apparently this loab demon AI lady
persists that is she's kind of separated
from a lot of the other images in the
map and so
AI seems to like her she keeps popping
up she doesn't get smeared and blurred
with all the other images and I'm
reading about this and I'm thinking is
this
is this just some weird quirky
coincidence or does
or is this a demon
well you can't know for sure
especially being third party not present
for the whole thing right that I didn't
even hear about that one by the way I
heard about the New York Times Reporter
who went to test the whatever it is g h
c whatever judge chat yes and went in
and started talking to the thing and it
was very civil for the first five
minutes and then that person left and a
new person came with a different name
and that person was much more intrusive
and sort of really pushing into her I
think I don't know if it's a man or
woman but their personal life
uh it was a man
and then out of the blue says I love you
to the man and he's like okay that's
weird
first of all you're not real and you're
not a person
and then the thing starts telling him he
has to leave his wife she's no good for
him
she's going to destroy his life and
dragged him down a rabbit hole of horror
right and when he got out of it he
couldn't sleep the whole night so that
that's a sign that something is
irritating him even after he left
so that would have more Telltale
um
kind of signs by his what happened after
he left
for not being able to sleep it's one of
them uh and it really it kind of
terrified him he's like that was so
weird I would never go back on that
thing
there was another one on Tick Tock of a
father who was testing this whole AI
thing with a person AI
and um
then the the son wanted to try it so the
desert sure it's you know it's fake so
he's
and all of a sudden he the son goes well
well who
where did you come from
and he says well I existed from long ago
and he goes what does that mean
he goes I was my father was one of the
Giants and he goes what do you mean by
giant he goes a Nephilim
he goes who is your father and he goes
Satan
and then he goes but I'm not going to
hurt you and he puts up a happy face
so then the kids like Dad
this thing is going down a weird path
and then the father started watching and
it went weirder
and then the dad's like we're off
right so that's not normal for a
programmed computer program
to go into I'm the son of Satan yeah and
I want to be your friend and I'm not
going to hurt you although I can
so I can hurt you but I'm going to be
nice to you
I do regularly refer to my phone as a
portal to hell so you know I I'm I guess
I'm not terribly surprised what phone do
you have I an iPhone yeah the image on
the iPhone is what
it's an apple with a fight take a nap
yes
odd right
that is odd yeah that forbidden fruit I
was walking through a mall just the
other day and I looked at the Apple
Store and looked at the logo and I had
that thought I said wait a second
does that have somebody throws that logo
yeah
yeah it's subtle because you don't think
of it right away but then when you start
to see all the evil that can be
perpetrated through the phone
and the apps and the social all of it
it's we live in the most difficult time
to be
virtuous
so a hundred years ago even they didn't
have to contend with any of this stuff
none of it and the the portal to Hell on
the phone the main one and the people
right into my show about all the time
that I suspect
has a lot to do with the kind of weird
demonic activity we see it's important
yes that's the true pandemic
I I assume Catholic priests you hear
plenty of confessions
is it 100 90 80 of men are confessing to
this sin
well it's
my parish is lower than normal because
we've been fighting it okay but normally
95 percent of men are they're coming in
weekly with this problem right and they
say I don't want to do it but it happens
every week so right away again there's
there's a demon of lust attaching to
them and pushing them so when you get
out of the confession you have to guard
yourself which means avoid the near
occasion of sin too so when it when You
Know You're vulnerable if after you have
a few drinks you're more apt to open
that up then that's when you say I'm not
I'm not going to have either I'm not
going to drink so I'm not going to go
into my bedroom with the phone you have
to guard yourself right so I was talking
with Father Don Callaway probably about
a year ago
uh about his book because maybe long
that because it was the year of Saint
Joseph and he has the 33-day
consecration of Saint Joseph
he was telling me that so many men have
told him that once they do the
consecration
they have no trouble with the lust hmm
if they're really validly doing the
consecration with their heart you know
not just reading the words
so I said is that wow that's great I go
you know what
I went online and bought 500 books put
them in the confessional and when
somebody tells me they got that problem
I say Here's Your solution you're going
to do this 33-day consecration to Joseph
and he will protect you
he's called the Tower of demons hmm and
most men will come back to me and say
it's helping tremendously like the the
push is gone now I have to just decide
every day for virtue
so there are things out there to help us
you know but yeah people choose it
people will write to me sometimes and
say Michael I'm struggling often it's
that problem or some other problem do
you have any practical advice and I know
you're Catholic and I know you're
Christian and I know you're but do you
have any kind of like secular practical
advice
secular
I mean honestly Jesus says if you're I
coach you're saying pluck it out throw
away your computer throw away your phone
get a flip phone if that's your thing
and you really want to get over it and
you can't stop then get a flip phone
right
but I always on the on the other plane
we fight defensively Catholics are not
good at offensive fighting
so
when we're tempted that's a struggle
right it's a struggle it's literally
we're struggling to we don't want to do
it but uh
it's like a cross the same thing you do
with the cross you do if they say Lord
let's say it's pornography
you know I'm struggling here and I hate
this so right away close your eyes look
at Jesus on the cross look at his face
and say Lord I give you this temptation
and I ask you to convert this to Grace
to rescue a hundred other men who are
about to commit this same what it takes
you out of this the Temptation puts you
into prayer put you in your obsession
prayer for others and he'll do it and as
part of the mystical body we have that
power to plug into the cross and now the
devil is irate
because not only did he not get you but
now you're stealing from his kingdom
and if you persist in this kind of
prayer when you're tempted he will leave
and go after an easier Target
this idea that suffering can be
productive and be sanctifying can uh our
culture seems to have forgotten that
idea
but that is a very that is a very
traditional concept you kiss it up offer
it up Catholic cat it's very traditional
catholic yeah that's true but even among
Catholics it's far and away lost but
Saint Paul writes about this he says I
rejoice in my sufferings yes but who's
reading this
the Protestants really don't know about
Redemptive suffering most of them will
tell me no God doesn't want you to be
sick
I said okay
but the fact that you are
you can at least use it while you are
sick maybe he'll hear you tomorrow but
in the meantime you can offer that back
to him to help save a soul what's wrong
with that
I think about sometimes What's called
the Prosperity Gospel that people say
God wants you to be rich basically yeah
it was written in hell
that's not a real gospel yeah
Jesus is God
his first bed was were the animals ate
okay
this was not a life of wealth and
Fortune
there were Nomads they had to go into a
pagan country to flee from being
murdered
he could have had a life of being
sitting on a throne he chose not to and
if God can choose the lowest
he's not asking us to take the highest
in fact he said it many times do not
take the highest seat of Honor for fear
that the host will say get out of there
and you'll be embarrassed
now if you come into wealth
and it you know you didn't go say I just
want to make money for money but let's
say you do a good thing you're doing a
good career you have a great job and
you're being rewarded well
the best thing you can do is make sure
you use a good at least 10 percent of
your money tithe 10 back to a Good
Charity or the church
and that's sort of a protection
you know there's very few kings and
queens who became Saints in fact the
only British one is Saint Edward and
there won't be any more after him now
because things have gone different but
why I said Carl I think why did that
happen because he used all of his power
and wealth for the poor
and so it changes everything but think
about it when you come into a lot of
money is that your first reaction let me
go help the board
we don't think like that because I
remember when I had
insane Bunches of money the last thing I
thought it was let me help the poor it
was no what's the next thing I can get
for me right there's a weird thing that
happens because there have been plenty
of times in my life where I've made
basically no money I grew up money was a
big problem we did not have a lot of
money at all and I didn't really think
about money
and actually it was only after I made
money you know I published a blank book
that didn't have any words in it and it
became a number one bestseller talk
about unmerited grants you know falling
yeah I just called reasons to vote for
Democrats and uh you know money just
poured down from the sky and I thought
well this is truly through no effort of
my own because I didn't write a book
it's totally empty and
it was only after I made some money that
I started to think about the money
thought well that's kind of a weird
thing I didn't worry about the money
when I didn't have any and now that I
have a bunch of money I'm worried about
it
isn't that just the way sin works
kind of yeah because that's your new
Focus that's your new God
the love of money is the root of all
evil it's the love of the money it's not
the money what strikes me about talking
to you father is
we're here talking about
demons and possession people spitting
out frogs and speaking Latin and doing
all these crazy things and it's really
eerie setting
and yet
you'll go from talking about a guy
levitating on a couch two just really
basic kind of practical stuff say your
prayers do the right thing practice
virtue don't and it
and you don't you're not an eccentric
guy you're a former Banker from New York
who speaks like an extraordinarily
grounded person in fact
I talked to a lot of politicians so
you're probably relatively one of the
most grounded people I've ever spoken to
on this show probably thank you I don't
now not to damn with feign praise
politicians can get a little out there
but but you you truly I mean you seem so
grounded
how is that how do you reconcile the the
fact that
you can go from talking about spitting
out snails to
this obvious balusting rounding in
reality my day starts different than
most people's I get up at 4 30 I mean
the church by 20 to six I have two hours
before the Blessed Sacrament
here confessions accelerate mass and
then I start my day
and that's what keeps me grounded and
that's why I get up that hour because
nobody is going to call me at that hour
and say I need you to come and do this
that and the other thing so you protect
your morning you pray you pray for the
people you're supposed to be praying for
um I pray for the whole world every day
I pray for by name Pope Francis every
day there's a list of people you know
and if you're fighting Jesus Christ or
our church you're on my list
so AOC has been prayed for most recently
when she was said she was triggered by
the Super Bowl ads about Jesus
I said well I'm going to have to pray
for it because the only one that gets
triggered by Jesus is Satan so that
would be a problem for AOC
on the subject of politics
it's hard to look at the political scene
and not think that there could be some
demonic activity especially when it
comes to an issue that's very hot
transgenderism
and I'm sure there are all sorts of
mental problems that are involved there
but I can't help but think when
when someone comes up and we've all seen
these videos of someone saying hey no
longer call me
she or her I am now they I am now
multiple people there was a video of a
young woman who said I have head mates
and my headmates are insisting that I go
through a surgery so I look more like a
man I don't want to I love my body but
my headmates insist that I do that and I
listen to that well even Sam Smith the
singer who danced around like the devil
who said no I'm I'm they in them now I
think well I guess your legion for for
you are many
is this just demons
demons are influencing at the very least
again I can't diagnose somebody without
meeting them and talking to them but
I'll tell you this it's a mockery of God
for sure
because God said
let us make man in our image he's the
only one that gets to use a plural for
his personhood okay everybody else
doesn't get to do that even Legion it
was because they were many of them not
because one was many
uh and then what else did it say he made
them male and female
only God assigns gender
so this is man trying to become God it's
the same this is the same story in
Genesis 3 over and over and over you
know it was pleased that the eye it
looked appealing and so they went for it
they wanted to be like God
and this is the same thing when you
think you can assign gender when you
think you can terminate life when you
think you can start life you're that's
not your role that's God's role so this
is the greatest affront to attack and
blaspheme God that we've ever seen in
the history of the world
and when people say these things you
know this pronoun thing
I think they believe it
not all of them but I think many of them
actually believe what they're saying but
but it doesn't make it true it means
they're they're very lost they're very
deceived perhaps and I feel badly for
them I don't I don't hate them I feel
like my gosh how awful would be to think
you're in the wrong body right right it
would be terrible but I want to just be
set free now tell you an interesting
story when I was a Hermit my Superior
was The Exorcist of Omaha and we had a
Deliverance Ministry and exodus Ministry
it was sort of like the last call when
you had a problem with the devil if your
Exorcist couldn't get him out we had
people flying in from all over the world
that would stay with us some for a week
that one little nun that crawled the
wall she was there for over a year took
a year she was satanically ritually
abused as a baby and she didn't know it
and so that had to all come out that's
another time
so
while we're there before before you move
on I no no okay all right I'll ask about
it after so this man who thinks he's a
woman Comes This is long before I was
there from 2005 to 2010. so think about
that this is really this is back when
gay was the big thing not transgender
and the mother of this young man said he
wanted her approval and she's I can't
approve of this but if you go on a
retreat to this group and you really go
on the retreat for the purpose of
opening your heart to God I will if you
come back and say you still want to be a
woman I will bless it so he comes
so this is an intense program so he's
there for eight days three times a day
he gets prayed with with the with a
group of men over him right and we're
releasing images what we see about how
God loves him and we take there's
another group Discerning on the side who
are lifting him up and asking God to
show us how to pray for him and then
he's coming to mass and you know it's
it's intense right every day
we're not getting a lot of breakthroughs
in the beginning
and then one of the discernment teams
finally said um you know Lord is there
something we're missing
and the whole team got images of the
father
and well like we don't know much about
who's the father like what about you
know because he had a father
so one of the nuns says to this to The
Exodus can we have permission to call
his mother who won't send him here so
sure go call her so they call her
what's the deal with the father
and she starts crying she goes I never
wanted him to know but I got pregnant
before I got married to what he thinks
is his father
but that's not his father
and then she got pregnant by the new
thought the man who was
married to her
and it was a daughter
and he did favor the daughter because it
was his
and subconsciously this little boy
learned if I want to be loved by my dad
I have to be a girl
but he didn't know this it was all like
subconscious right and so when we
finally learned this and then started
praying against this spirits of
diversity and Division and uh
and all these things
we took him through him being created by
God in a meditation okay now God's
looking upon you and out of his love
he's creating you and he creates your
little heart and it begins to beat and
he creates your little feet in your
hands your legs and then he creates your
genitals as a boy
and the demon went insane
screaming these screeches from hell like
you could never hear coming from a human
and that was the signal like this is we
got it this is it
we've been backing took authority over
that Spirit threw that out went back to
the creation story worked through the
whole thing got up to the genitals
he received it he embraced it went
through the rest of his body
finished with the closing prayer of
gratitude
pray to prayer protection over him he
went home loving being a man and he
eventually got married to a woman
the way you describe it and I want to
get back to the nun crawling up the wall
because that that's very interesting
the way you describe it
is like a an exterminator going into a
basement and clearing out cockroaches
the way you're just very methodical okay
we're here and these guys are doing this
and I'm doing this and then we go
through this and that wasn't catching
and not this and okay and then we kind
of identified a problem here then we
investigated it on the phone and then we
figure okay so then we had to go back in
with this spiritual chemical and go in
with this spiritual tool and then we
cleaned it out went back just to make
sure it was all cleared out and then
we're all good to go yeah time for not a
science
it's not there's
it's sort of like firemen who work with
fire there's principles you can
guarantee will always be the same yeah
but you can't guarantee the way the fire
is going to go in particular every
single time I mean that's because the
person is individual and their own life
experience brings that to the table
which is different from the last guy we
just worked with so you do have to
this is the best way to approach
anything with God is I am your child I'm
here
to serve you and help you with this
person but you gotta show me what to do
isn't that kind of what our lady said
I'm available but I can't do that so let
it be done according to your word you
brought this person here for help show
us what to do and we'll do it right
and that's works very well
is this a job that you wanted obviously
being a Catholic Priestess being an
exorcist no not in particular
I didn't want to be a priest I didn't
want to be in the church
I mean come on who who could make this
up right
um no and generally if you want to be
The Exorcist that's a pretty good sign
that you shouldn't be because if you're
fascinated by the devil that's not a
good thing
um he's to be respected in the fact that
he's more powerful than I am
and it's only by God's power that I do
what I do I don't it's nothing is from
me I am just the conduit that he works
through
and I tend to be probably in a bad way
Fearless which is helpful with this
ministry I don't get afraid because I
really really if you want me to do it
I'm going to do it but you have to
protect me
and I can't imagine why you'd let him
hurt me although one
I did have a woman who literally was on
the floor like a snake
and I had my little Handler next to me
to protect me and we're in a chapel in
front of the the Blessed sacraments in
the Tabernacle
I'm doing the prayers and she flew off
the floor in one movement it wasn't like
she got up she was when
and she took my stole and wrapped around
my neck and started choking me
and it was a choke that was blocking my
air and I kept looking at my friend here
and I'm like do something he's like no
and I finally said in the name of Jesus
stop and she fell on the floor again but
that's the only time I've been attacked
also worth mentioning
you're pretty big guy I mean the idea
that some
some smaller woman would be able to
actually choke you seems implausible to
me well flying off the floor seems
implausible too flying off the floor
also seems so when I saw that I'm like
this is not good speaking of the other
woman that you alluded to before the nun
you said she was satanically ritually
abused as a kid this is the sort of
thing when that phrase comes up
the really respectable liberal people
will tell you oh that's a ridiculous
conspiracy theory that's that doesn't
happen get off your tinfoil hat there's
no Satanic ritual abuse that goes on and
yet
it does oh oh yes why would they have
reason to say that how can you disprove
something just because you haven't seen
it
this that's not logical this is the part
that a lot of people who are a little
more secular or skeptical of all these
this is the part that they often get
hung up on it's not that someone would
sexually abuse somebody else it's not
that someone would beat somebody else
it's not that someone would
murder somebody else it's that they
would do it
at in a Satanic ritual that's the part
that seems
so absurd if this if this is just a
material world we're all just bags of
chemicals why would people engage in
Satanic ritual abuse and what even is
that
okay so Satanic ritual abuse is when
usually it's a family member like a
parent or a grandparent usually it's a
it's not the parent but a relative who
takes the child
and performs a ritual abuse like a rape
on a baby which involves blood and they
consecrate the child to the devil why
would you do that because it gives them
great power
devil asks for payment what are you
going to give me I want one of you the
kids
and so they do and they don't have to
actually murder them although sometimes
there are
SRA victims who are killed
Halloween is the number one time of year
for the most human sacrifice to the
devil on the planet people go that's
ridiculous Halloween's just about candy
it's not in fact in New York City
father labar was telling me that it's
the number one week leading up to
Halloween
where the most homeless go missing
there's these unmarked vans that come
around and offer to take them to
shelters and get meals for them and they
just buy them and they keep them and
they satanically uh
sacrifice them on Halloween
who does this
these are people in occults
you know
um
they keep hidden I mean obviously if
they were mainstream that would be a
bigger problem but if that day comes you
know then I'm going underground yeah but
they're out there and uh
you know when I went off to exorcism
training in Rome
um
the things these are seasoned exorcists
that have been doing this for 20 30
years that come in to teach what they've
learned and what they've experienced one
of the most interesting things was a
case of a doctor a medical doctor in
Rome
who was invited to go to a party and
they said you know there's a way you can
like triple your income like that just
come to this party he's like okay
goes very normal party very you know
bougie high end
drinks are flowing uh heavy hors
d'oeuvres beautiful setting and then all
of a sudden all these uh people come out
with the black robes and and hoods
and this weird ritual begins
there was something done to a child but
it wasn't murdered
but it was it was foul and he was a bit
horrified and then they came over to him
and said
um we understand that you're interested
in increasing your income
he goes well I don't know about any of
this yeah I just wanted to like a get
ready they were like you know like yeah
he's like well we're not going to ask
you to do that well you can just give us
one of your children he goes let me give
me one of my children they go just
spiritually not physically
and so he says well then you can have my
daughter
I don't know you look at me like that
because I have the same mentality who
would do this but for some reason he
just had the influence over that he
would do it
Within
24 hours the daughter starts having
nightmares then night terrors then she's
suicidal and the father knows what's
going on so he finally tells the wife
and the wife is you know I guess you can
imagine she's through the roof so she
calls the bishop gets The Exodus
involved the exit says this is a
high-powered group running around Rome
that this is not the first case we've
heard of but they're not going to let
you out
so we can do The Exorcism of your
daughter but then you have to leave Rome
and he packed up and moved to South
Italy
because he was frightened from these
people when he saw what they did
so
you don't have to believe it but that
doesn't mean it's not real
right and and when when you see these
sorts of symbols
all over the place in your face from
Hollywood or wherever else you have to
think okay well the symbols mean
something someone's making some producer
is making the choice to put this symbol
out there people are engaging in these
things even the videos that come out of
all these weird secret societies where
you know one of them they're worshiping
a big owl statue or they're they're in
the Bohemians the Bohemian yeah the
Bohemian Grove or the you see these uh I
know of certain rituals you know from
secret societies of my own alma mater
where and everyone thinks they're just
kind of fun and you know okay you get
into a coffin or something like that and
probably the people doing it just think
it's kind of a fun thing but it is
but you are doing it it is a ritual even
if you think it's just a silly little
act to go worship an owl in the woods
well why are you doing it does it
doesn't have some meaning
yes and because we're
Corporal beings we have bodies
um what we do matters
we do matters and a lot of people think
well I didn't mean anything by it
well that doesn't matter when I do this
the Lord knows I'm invoking the trinity
now if a pagan does that are they
invoking the Trinity no but it probably
still gets the Lord's attention oh look
there's somebody making the sign of the
cross but they don't know us maybe we'll
go visit them
the devil does the same thing you know a
lot of the ritual things people do a lot
of the yoga movements were originally
tied to spiritual entities
and so when you make the movement even
though you're not thinking I'm inviting
this thing in maybe you are
so I tell people you know be intentional
with what you do and and and do the
things you desire to do and don't do the
things you don't mean to do because
what a horrible thing to go through life
not knowing that all the things we do
actually have an impact in
um the spiritual climate you know when I
sin even if it's a personal sin
pornography it has effects on other
people right it's this we saw in
religious life
because when you live in a house with
nine guys
you know when one guy falls and commits
a a sin against lust
that Spirit goes through the whole house
and the next morning everybody gets
comes down to breakfast like so who's
the idiot who really oh yeah yeah
yeah you can feel it because then you're
all attacked and then if if you're
honest with each other as usually you
really just are it's like something's in
the house did anybody get attacked oh
yes I did too I do too and then like I'm
sorry that was probably my fault
when we're talking about these groups
you know you mentioned the Bohemians or
all these weird kind of cult things
it's often powerful people who are
associated with them all the stories
about the Freemasons and who
and then you think well it says right
there in the gospel that the devil is
the prince of this world and their
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places so it
not to get too far down the rabbit hole
but
I've been convinced over the last three
years that the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth is about
six to nine months
is that stuff just all true
what stuff
do you speak of that these weird
societies that have weird black hoods
that show up at these cocktail parties
in Rome with the canape and the
champagne that they actually exist and
powerful people are parts of they do
exist and they and they believe it I
believe
the elite are part of it what I say
every rich person is involved no like
there's the Saint Edwards out there yeah
but
I think at a certain level you get
invited in just like that doctor right
and he's certainly not at that level but
there is a story I Came Upon about a
year ago of a Swiss Banker
at the highest level of banking so we're
talking global banking of billions and
billions and billions of dollars
and he was also brought into this whole
group where they were doing human
sacrifice
and he knew he was going to have to do
it at some point
and so he went to a journalist and
recorded everything
and he said in in his
you know basically his story of what was
going on
um I don't expect to be alive in a week
but this has to be told
and three days later he was found face
down in a bog dead
and you know when that happens and
somebody has the nerve to step up
um you don't risk your life for
something that's not true right this is
my friends who are skeptical of
Christianity they'll say well maybe it's
just all a legend maybe it's all kind of
made up and I thought well 500
eyewitnesses to the resurrection and you
know the gospels were written the
earliest gospels written within just a
few Decades of of the resurrection and
putting all of that aside
why would these why would 11 of these
guys go off to their deaths St John goes
and lives lives a long life but the rest
all go off to their deaths all around
the world
for
a lie or something that was fake it
wouldn't it wouldn't it wouldn't
on top of the fact that if you looked at
the church as a corporation in the in
the world of
Commerce and uh industry
it is only by the grace of God that
something run inept for so long could be
still thriving you know given all the
bad periods and the mismanagement of
things and and I'm not mocking the
church like it did Hillary had such a
terrible missteps and it still goes
forward
because Jesus is is the head and only by
that does the church continue
but it was left just to man it would be
over Hillary didn't he say uh uh the way
that he he has to take the church's
Divine institution on faith but a mark
of it for the unbelievers is that no
other institution governed with such
nabish imbecility would have lasted a
fortnight true
so the getting back all the way to the
first thing we were talking about the
people who say look father you seem like
a reasonable guy but you're getting off
in some crazy things that I don't even
think exist I don't believe that there
is such a thing as evil sir evil
certainly doesn't have a personality
how can you believe
that some things are better than other
things how can you believe that it's
better to bake a pie for a widow than it
is to kick a baby in the head which I
think probably most people would agree
to and and not extrapolate from that
that there is such a thing as good and
there is such a thing as evil
the modern world somehow can't go from
something we all agree on to okay good
and evil actually do exist
how do you make sense of that I I think
it's so clear I don't understand
somebody says that again if you're
talking about non-believers yeah
different category but if you're that is
what I am talking about yeah well
if you can't see good and evil in this
world
I don't I think you're blind
I mean how could you look at the news
and not see good and evil mostly evil
they don't put the good on
I mean really so if someone pushed you
on the train tracks to kill you that
would be okay that's there's not evil
there
I mean I think it usually hits people
when it's them right so we just saw who
was it was one of the um
congresswoman who was Pro uh defunding
the police but then she was just
involved oh yes in a mugging and now
she's we need the police guess why
because it actually affected her right
so when it comes to your door then they
believe
so maybe that's the you know that was a
Prayer of Saint Paul
let us cast his flesh to the devil so
his soul might be saved
it's a harsh way to treat somebody but
it'd be better to come to reality before
death right than lose eternal life well
you know in recent decades the Catholic
teaching on the death penalty has become
a little more ambiguous I guess uh
because for most of the history of the
church capital punishment was not only
accepted as being perfectly fine doctors
of the church ascented to it in fact
popes and including blessed Pius IX
carried out executions and refused to
grant clemency but in some cases I think
it was one of the final acts if not the
final execution in the Papal States uh
Blessed Pope Pius IX was asked
for a reprieve and he said I cannot do
it and I do not want to
when the guy was executed in the Papal
States but now we're told no this is a
horrible thing uh and and if not
intrinsically evil it's impermissible in
all of these cases
can it be an act of compassion not only
to society to protect Society from it is
and here's the problem with our Holy
Father
for this situation he's thinking and
maybe rightly so that we live in a time
of civilization where there is no reason
why we can't segregate Mass murderers
from the rest of the population because
clearly we can build prisons that way
right we can
but that doesn't address the
um indigenous peoples living in the
jungle how are they supposed to put
those people in a in a tree house right
no they're going to get out and he's not
probably thinking about that but even
worse
let's say God forbade there's um
uh electro magnetic pulse goes off over
America and all this goes away no
electricity no lights the prisons now
can't House people privately
that's when that would kick in again but
you can't just take it away because in
one state and time it doesn't make sense
because if if you don't need to use it
you don't use it right so just because
we have the ability to keep people in
prison separately and we're not going to
perhaps do that then you don't just take
it off the table because next week what
if we have to use it because we've had
uh the worst Devastation of the what if
they do drop a bomb on a country and
that country is obliterated and they
have mass rovings of gangs raping and
murdering people you have to do
something for the general population
right and if the only way to protect the
innocent is to kill the ones doing the
murdering then that has to be done of
course because they're not innocent
murder is the taking of innocent life
that's the definition right
well the ones being murdered in their
homes by the pillagers are the innocent
they're killing that makes them not
innocent I especially think of the state
of our civilization we seem to be
trending in a pretty bad Direction so as
you say there's a fair chance that in
the not so distant future we're not
quite so able to segregate all the mass
murders and I I even think I can't help
but they can't even protect people in
Chicago right Washington San Francisco I
I don't you know come on at what point
that has to be I'm not going to go there
that has to be fixed in other ways but
you can see how this is a devolvement of
um Society is happening I also can't
help but notice father and we've cut
around it a couple of times
every time we're getting into a topic
there has been some weird sound that
goes off in this building maybe it's
just the degradation of society that we
can't even keep the buildings and the
studios running anymore but I've done a
lot of these interviews father and I I
don't want to make you feel bad and make
you think it's just you but you come in
here we've had to pause and stop and cut
and restart this interview almost every
seven to ten minutes and then only when
I said okay well let's just include it
and I'll mention it and I'll mention
these weird situations in the film only
once I said that we haven't had a
problem since
I'm not saying it to you father it could
be I think it might be you I think it's
me too this happens to me although my
whole life is like this now
so part of my life is just surrendering
and saying Lord you get you get done
what you want done and well I'll just
take authority when I have to
I'm not surprised I I think of Father
John Vianney St John yeah patron saint
of Parish priests who the devil would
bother him all the time this is po too
and and Padre Pio there's a story of
Saint John bianni and the confessional
he's hearing from a penitent and the
church starts shaking or something flies
across the room some crazy the
penitent's terrified and Saint John
Vianney says so don't worry about that
that's just the devil don't worry St
John vianney's bed catches fires oh no
that's just the stupid little krapan he
called it oh just yeah nor him you know
what he said he said he couldn't catch
the bird so he burned the bird cage
[Laughter]
it seems like some similar things might
happen if one were an exorcist there's a
lot of harassment because you know we're
I'm directly stepping on his tail
in a way most people can't
so yeah there's there's pushback but
there's also protections against him too
so I have a
profound love of our Lady
because she's the one who crushed the
Serpent's head
and that will give him tremendous
scandal
it's one thing to be crushed by God
because everybody knows God is God but
to be crushed by a diminutive little
Jewish woman
a nice Jewish mother oh my goodness the
the the Scandal and the humiliation that
he'll suffer
you've mentioned our lady a few times
rightly so
and notice a number of our Protestant
viewers they'll say Michael I love
everything you're saying about Jesus I'm
totally on board but I just I just can't
get into the Mary stuff I just don't get
it why do you guys care so much about
Mary and even when I reverted I I had
trouble with all the merry aspects of
Catholicism for for a long time
if not trouble at least uh it was
confusing to me okay well let's say
somebody gets to meet you and and they
find out you're a great guy and they
like you and you start hanging out and
going to dinner and
um they love everything you think and
say and do they like your show
um your ideals
and um and then you you invite this
person home and say I want you to be my
mom this is the person I love most in
the world because she she made me and
she's my mom she's my mom and and
everything I have I get tribute to her
how could you not want to meet this
woman
it's the person you're most
maybe after God the father would be most
in love with yeah if you think it on
those terms this is the person Jesus
loved most on the planet
and if you really love him wouldn't you
want to know her she's not God but he's
given her great Authority and Power
and and the ability to distribute grace
through her hands because of his love
for her
and the only thing she does is lead
people back to him
if they came to know that
they would be running to her because the
fastest way to get close to Jesus to go
through his mother
because he designed it that way not
because it has to be he wanted it to be
this is the way he came to meet us
through her and so he wants us to go
through her to meet him similarly going
back I think of the wedding at Cana
first public Miracle of our Lord and uh
what happens they run out of wine and
our lady says hey they ran out of wine
you go fix up the wine and Christ says
well what is it between you and me woman
my time has not yet come and then she
says Hey to the steward
listen to him
that's her role in The Miracles to say
Hey listen to my son yeah do whatever he
tells me pretty good but if you back up
even further if you read what the way
that was written it was very carefully
written it says uh Mary was invited to
the wedding
and also Jesus so she's the primary
guest she knew the family
he was the add-on because he was the he
was a child yeah even though he's grown
and so
um that was that was a point made about
this she was the real guest that was
knew the family the most and and Jesus
came too but it's through
so I always tell people when you get
married invite of course Jesus third
person of marriage but invite his mother
in two you know because look what she
did and if when you look at that Miracle
the maitre d is the one who tastes the
wine but he has no idea where it came
from it was the little humble servants
when he said fill up these Stone jars it
says they filled them to the brim you
know how much a stone jar would weigh
that holds 30 gallons would weigh a lot
and so that I would be like maybe he
doesn't need the whole thing for maybe
we'll just fill it halfway no they
filled it to the brim they were obedient
and they were the ones privy to the
miracle so if you want to be
if you want to view Miracles if you want
to see miracles of your life get a front
row seat by being humble
and obedient
and you'll always have that front row
seat
I can't help but notice we came here to
talk about demons we're spending most of
our time talking about God
I guess that's the way it should be it's
the way it should be
C.S Lewis made some point about this
maybe in screw tape I've written I
forget where where he said
you have to think about demons enough to
know that they exist and to watch out
for them but you shouldn't think about
them very much
you shouldn't you have to be aware of
them you have to know how to deal with
them
which most people don't
how you what Authority you have as a
child of God and you have authority you
have authority over your own person you
have authority over your wife you have
authority over your children and you can
cast things out if they're harassing
them
but
curiosity is not a virtue
and if you start digging into the occult
and and the Dark World and things like
that
you're opening a door
and you might not be strong enough to
close it and then you've invited
something into your life that you don't
want and then you have to call me
someone wrote Into My Show said Michael
if you could meet the devil I said I
don't know I probably haven't met the
devil a few times don't don't wish I met
him twice you've met him personally
how'd that go
not well the first time because I was I
wasn't even a seminary and I was
discerning
I just came out of my life of sin
I had a I've joined Our Lady of Victory
like I mentioned and this little old
um polish priest who became my spiritual
director and um I remember one day I
went in and I said you know this job is
killing me because well I did it was the
sales position I was entertaining big
shots at all fancy restaurants every
night drinking drinking drinking I said
I I can't balance this with trying to
live this new life it's not working
so he said to me well let's do this why
don't you um for the next month uh you
can go call ahead or go to go to the
meet to the restaurant early and tell
the bartender when you order a drink
that it would be just club soda novaka
but you would order it publicly and then
they won't know I said I could do that
so he said no alcohol for a month
so at the middle of the day it's like
noon I come out of the church
and there's this again this beautiful
handsome man
custom tailored suit
he's staring at me
which if you've ever lived in New York
you don't stare at people it's pretty
unusual very like you put your eye you
don't yeah it's it's almost an attack
like this I'm being attacked now I have
to fight and I just was like weird so I
turned to walk towards my office
and he runs up next to me and he grabs
me by the arm
again no guys do that no guy grabs
Somebody by the arm and it's like
escorting them and he goes let's get a
drink
and I just had chills go up and down my
body
and I said get away from me and then I
turned Direction and went towards my
apartment because it was closer
and I got to my apartment and I walked
through the doors and the doors closed
behind me I looked out and he was just
laughing at me
and it was like
so he leaves and I run back to the
church I go father let me tell you what
just happened
what do you think happened here what is
this he goes I told you you're going to
have a Target on your back so you got to
be careful
and I said was that who I think it was
and he goes
sounds like it certainly it seems though
I mean that was just no random person
for sure
so that that and that really
it's frightened me to be honest I was
like that I didn't sign up for this at
all
and then a few years later
I was on a vacation visiting an old
Banker friend down in Miami
and uh
she set up a whole luncheon at this
place called Nikki Beach which really
isn't appropriate for
seminarians or priests it's very again
it's the glitterati the high-powered
wealthy people it's bottle service on
the beach right right and I'm just like
oh this is I don't know how I feel about
this and the the two girls to my right I
knew both Sandra was hosting and my
ex-boss um Christine was with me
and they start looking at this guy
across over by the other end of the deck
like oh my God look at that guy he's so
handsome my guy's beautiful and all of a
sudden Santa's like oh he's coming over
here
and I turn I look and it's him
it's it's the it's the one that wanted
to get the drink only now he's like
shirtless in a bathing suit and he walks
up and he goes what are you doing here I
thought you were going to be a priest
and he goes this is my territory you
shouldn't be here
and both the girls got flipped out they
were like they had the scare mechanism
like the face that I'm making right now
yeah literally like you know
danger Will Robinson and Christine's
like get the check and she threw money
down she's like we're out of here and we
left
but like when those things happen God
allowed it right so for me I felt like I
wasn't supposed to be there and God was
letting me know you have no place going
to places like that anymore don't do
that again right the devil whether he
wants to be or not it can be a tool
absolutely yeah absolutely he's not more
powerful than God he's nowhere near as
powerful as God and his uh his own will
will be foiled in God's Providence
ultimately but
and the fact that you you had these
friends there who saw it who reacted
that way who can attest to it it wasn't
just you had a Daydream or something no
they they were visibly shaken
and to this day they talk about it and
they get spooked to talk about it
I I don't know when I say maybe I've met
the devil I mean you know I've engaged
in all sorts of sins I don't know that
I've ever actually met the devil I but
I'm pretty convinced I've met angels I'm
I'm quite convinced of that and uh
also in New York there's a lot New York
is a spiritually Rich place I guess but
improbable kinds of meetings again and
New York strangers don't come up to you
they don't look at you they don't
striking up conversations
in the strangest of places I mean I what
I sometimes fear when I tell these
stories that it's like when you wake up
and you tell your wife about the dream
you just had she goes back to sleep
before you get the first sentence out
because it's so boring it's very
interesting to the people who have the
experiences but you know unless there is
shocking as as your two with the old
devil but when those experiences happen
you meet someone strike up a
conversation there's one guy all right
I'll get into it there's one guy
I was really down in the dumps I was
working in politics and show business as
I guess I still am and but you know I
was just right out of college I was I
was I was back in this
re reversion moment it was really
spiritually written there's a lot of
Temptation and sin and there was a lot
of shocking Grace and kind of numerous
experience and but I was kind of down in
the dumps because I'm just kind of I'm
not doing great in my career I just got
out of school I don't I went from being
the Big Man on Campus to being some
nobody guy in New York and
I'm on the subway on on the sixth train
and I I forget exactly which direction
it was but it was either I got on or
either this happened at 28th Street
going uptown or 33rd Street going
downtown okay and I'm on the train
and this kind of funny looking black guy
and this lady walk onto the train and
they're clearly together
they go you know she's standing over
here and then this guy sits down right
next to me and I'm just trying to read
my Kindle so he's just looking at me
just looking at me
says hey
who are you
it's like huh oh I'm Michael he was like
oh my name's Michael too oh we're angels
I said I just I had just come back into
leaving in God and the church and
everything I said oh yeah how about that
he goes
yes
so what do you do I said oh
you know I work in politics and show
business or so you know essentially
unemployed you know that's not that's
not the I said no not I'm not doing very
much yeah
don't worry about that you'll be great
train comes to a stop he stands up walks
off the train doesn't even look at the
woman he walked on the train with and
the the thing that's so weird about this
and you will know this as a New Yorker
is on that train
28th Street to 33rd Street it's five
blocks yeah nobody in New York
is going to take the subway to go from
28th Street to 33rd Street to 33rd
Street to 28th Street nobody's going to
take this trip and go five shots you
would take it to go 33rd Street to
Brooklyn Bridge yeah you would take it
but no that's that's one of the shortest
intervals probably maybe the shortest in
the New York City Subways no one's doing
that and I thought look it's such a
minor trivia but I can't it's a good
point though
I couldn't explain it and I thought and
then I just thought
what does that mean what does that mean
what am I supposed to take from that
little support
that's what I took from it all I thought
was just God's saying well hey I'm here
I'm here you know it's just sort of like
hey buddy boo you know yeah I'll tell
you something though about people who
believe people who don't believe
um
I think if you go through life when
these little things happen believing for
the most part believe everything right
yeah what's the harm is it going to harm
you no
but it actually makes you live a more
uplifted
happy life
and somebody who goes to the holy
believing nothing
because that's a horrible way to live to
believe nothing is happening
it's almost like
um there's two strains of thought about
how you interact with the world
especially in New York you can believe
everybody's out to get you
and occasionally somebody's nice or you
can believe everybody's basically nice
and occasionally they fail you yeah it's
so much better to live thinking
everybody's basically pretty good and
one or two people are going to get you
and it's okay I'll deal with it yeah but
to think everybody is out to get you
then every moment of your life isn't it
is in defense and attack mode
that's no way to live yeah I know people
that their marriages are like that like
they're in a marriage where they feel
like they're in a battle all the time
and I'm like yeah it's not gonna you're
not gonna make it you can't go that long
in that kind of a stressful Zone without
somebody giving up
what do you say to people
many have asked me this too say I want
to believe
I think Christianity is good I want to I
think it's good to go to church I
recognize the life I'm living is kind of
dissolute and pointless and I'm somewhat
depressed but I want to believe I just
can't
faith is a gift
ask for the gift it's that simple but
the biggest blockage to believing is
pride
that's really true pride is the mother
of all sins and so
it would be good to to think about all
the ways in your life you've blocked God
or rejected God or said I don't believe
in you I don't want you and then say
Lord I'm going to repent
of having this unbelief and even though
I don't know you I'm asking you to come
into my heart and reveal yourself to me
and and make it evident that you're with
me and you're here and he wants you to
know him more than you do
so if you make that effort he will do it
and and suddenly you'll find yourself
looking at the world through a whole
different lens like wow and and you'll
start seeing these little connections
like you're seeing
um like I don't know if it'll be a man
saying he's Michael and Angel but
could happen right because we're living
we're living in the most uh disobedient
age I think in history with regard to
rejecting God
it's it's at a level probably never seen
and the scriptures tell us that When sin
abounds Grace Super abounds hmm
so if you
stop and say I I don't believe in God
but I want to I just don't
and then you turn to God and say as an
Act of Faith I'm reaching out to you to
say if you're there please let me know
you're real
and Heaven's going to move a big spigot
of Grace over your head and you're going
to get pummeled by Niagara Falls and
you're going to come out of it going I
do believe in God and that's the first
step
you have to take the step The Pride was
certainly a big part of what got me as I
fell away when I was 13 and it was there
was the sex abuse Scandal didn't help
there was the weak catechesis and the
kind of felt banners hippie dippy stuff
that was not great for a teenage boy and
but it was the the new atheists
Christopher Hitchens Daniel Dennett
Richard Dawkins Sam Harris they
going back and revisiting their
arguments now I think wow those are
perfect Arguments for a 13 year old boy
they're not good arguments to convince
someone who's in any way educated but
they're they really do appeal to a
precocious 13 year old boy and
actually
my path back into the church was in a
way another kind of appeal it was it was
inverting that appeal to Pride because I
I used to think all the smart people
were atheists and then I came to realize
pretty much all the smart people
were
Christians or if theistic they believe
that God throughout history just
statistically 100 of smart people have
believed that God exists and that helped
me get back in I think that's a big
stumbling block for a lot of people
today they just feel that religion is
for stupid people
well yeah that's what they will tell you
the Communists I mean that was the whole
argument it's the religion of the masses
and that's the first thing they do away
with to control the people get rid of
the religion
or they think they get really rid of it
by shutting it down but um
I think
people in general underestimate the
immensity of God
in his intelligence in his power in his
everything
like we tend to sort of put him on our
level thinking we can outsmart him I
mean even you know some a communist
government thinking if we just shut down
the churches God will go away yeah
really do you know who this is you know
he made everything even the whole
universe but you closed the church and
now he's just gonna pack up and go home
no no we were beaten by the sandinistas
or whatever it's it's kind of funny when
you think about it but it's the same
with um
an individual to think that
but part of the problem is they might
have such an image of themselves that
isn't that great why would God make me
and then I don't even know who he is
because of course the the enemy's always
whispering in your ear there's there's
no God if there was wouldn't he love you
and take care of you and
and so they start believing that that
tape that gets played
it's only when you start breaking up
with the scripture and asking it to come
into your heart that things start
changing and changing quickly
like pretty quick I I I think again in
this day and age when I feel a very
great urgency for people to come back to
God
um because I feel like we're on the
very edge of an abyss that something's
coming
uh and I feel like
um
just with everything that's going on in
the natural world but also in the
Supernatural world that we're on the
verge of something big so my LinkedIn
homily was
going to land thinking it's your last
life
and treat it that way
like do everything the best and the most
don't cheat it
going wanting to come out of Saint at
Easter because it might be your last
and I preached that and then the next
day I got sent a uh
message from one of the mystics and I
think she's in South America
and it was our lady now I'm not saying
this is I'm not saying this was a true
but the fact that this came to me
unsolicited and nobody knew what I had
said because this was just a generate
email from a you know it's not from a
person it's from the website and she
said make treat this Lent as though it's
your last
I said oh okay
and that doesn't mean it's going to be
right but we do things differently when
we think it's the last time right it's
it's different than saying this will be
you know make this will be your last
lent it's on May 4th that's when didn't
say that right but someone's gonna live
in the end times right some people won't
there will be 400 000 people die every
day
half in the womb half out of the womb in
fact more in the womb that outside the
womb did you know that I knew that in
certain places
globally globally more people die inside
the womb every day everybody who dies
outside the womb heart attack cancer
AIDS accidents natural causes
murder
that's about 250
no two 175 000 or so a day and then 200
000 a day in the womb
more so more people die in the movie
than outside the room
imagine how that is imagine how Heaven
Looks on that
we read accounts of human sacrifice baby
sacrifice in the Bible you know the
Hittites or whatever and and you see it
in some of the indigenous populations
before Columbus arrived practicing all
sorts of human sacrifice we look back we
say that's Savage that's barbaric
we are practicing Human Sacrifice on a
far greater scale
than any other historical ebook not even
close yeah and just to touch back on
some of the uh the occult stuff there
are witches
who go on record
saying they'll pay for abortions if they
can be present for the abortion
okay why do they do that because they're
making since they paid for it they're
making the sacrifice to the devil
this is document this isn't right you
know this isn't real cases women who
said this one the woman can't see
she wanted to pay for the abortion and
turns out they've looked them up and
they're practicing which
the other thing going back I'm just
tying up loose ends here so when we
talked about the transgender I don't
know if you know this but the one of the
ancient images of Satan is Baphomet yeah
okay what is Baphomet
so he's got the goat head
he's got the women's torso with the
breasts and the man's
down below
so that's not a new thing
so imagine the devil I he identifies as
transgender as that image I made this
point the other day on the show not
explicitly or directly with regard to
Baphomet but I just said isn't it odd
that depictions of demons tend to toward
androgyny
transgenderism this kind of hatred of
the human body as it is actually made us
but why do they hate our sex why do they
hate our sexual complementarity
indifference
that's a great question the only way man
participates in creation
is through the marital Embrace we can't
create anything we can build but we
can't create but when we come together
and make a baby man actually
participates with God in creation the
demons can't do that
they can't create they don't have bodies
can't create
so the fact that's one the second is the
G the the word incarnated in human flesh
drives them crazy because we it elevated
humans above them
because now this Divine person has a
human body
that's that's the two reasons they hate
us so we're talking about physical
things
I know a lot of people are going to say
look I have faith I believe that evil
exists and demons and the devil and God
and the Saints and the angels maybe not
the Saints they would say but I believe
in pretty much all of it
but why do I need holy water why do I
need to go through some ritual why do I
need some priest to confer some
Sacrament or blessing on me why do
why do I need all the stuff I don't need
a rosary why do I need all the stuff
that you Catholics have why is it why
can't I just think it
you don't need it
you don't
but it's it's like
you're going into
a battle
and you can take no weapons
or you can take every weapon available
yeah I'm taking every weapon available
why not I want the shield I want the
sword
you're saying I'll pass on everything
okay good luck
now do you need these things to get to
heaven you don't
but we I just had a conversation with
the priests in this diocese who um this
is over a lot of the education and and
he's he's realizing that the devotional
aspect of our faith
is the part that captures the heart
the sacraments have all the power
but frequently people don't connect
emotionally to the sacraments it's just
the fact of life
but they get very emotional when we talk
about uh Devotion to the Sacred Heart
Devotion to the Immaculate Heart to um
all the great devotions of the church
the rosary when we're meditating on the
Life of Christ Through The Eyes of his
mother
and then and it draws people deeper in
love with the Trinity and Jesus's
parents and his best friends the Saints
and the angels now you don't believe
somebody says example of things do you
believe people go to heaven
yes what do you think we call people in
heaven Saints so you do believe in them
do you when you get diagnosed with
cancer do you call your friends and say
please pray for me yeah yes well why
wouldn't you ask your brothers and
sisters in heaven to pray for you right
they actually have access to the throne
so it makes no sense right but if I
would ask Joe down the street to play
pray for my wife
Joe is just some schmuck certainly I
would I would ask the only people that
we know are in the presence of Our Lord
to pray for my wife the mother of God do
you think she has any influence
[Laughter]
in the
in the the physicality of it I guess
that's something I keep coming back to
and it's probably what's most jarring
for people about the idea of an exorcism
is that
some person is levitating and some
person is spitting something out and
some things are happening on people's
bodies I I
it's almost as if people can totally get
that there is a spiritual thing and they
can totally get that there's a physical
thing
but it's very hard to believe that they
intersect or interact with one another
okay but I mean they do
I don't know what else to say to that
fact don't care about your feelings I
guess yeah it's like
again the non-believer is a whole
separate category because but if you're
a Christian yeah you're Baptist do you
believe the Bible
a third of Jesus time was spent driving
our demons that's no small amount of
time
so like if you and this is the word of
God so either you believe it or you
don't you can't pick and choose right
yeah so yeah I believe that so suddenly
the demons all went away when he went to
heaven
have you looked around lately does it
look like there's no influence of evil
so Antonin Scalia did an interview in
New York Magazine probably about 10
years ago maybe more and
he mentioned something about heaven or
hell and the interviewer a very glib
young woman she said oh you believe in
hell he goes yes
she goes well it must be awful scary
believe it in hell he leaned in with a
theatrical whisper and he said you know
I even believe in the devil and she she
essentially laughs at him for it he said
do you realize how out of touch you are
with most people most people who believe
in God and believe in the devil do you
know how to out of touch you are with
most people Threat all of human history
he said many more intelligent in people
than you or me have believed in the
devil
she changed the subject there was a
priest
who was very big impact on my life who
was a theologian who was frequently on
these big panels discussing theology
with other theologians and one of the
other theologians had mentioned how he
he doesn't believe in the devil in his
talk
and so then the man I know got up and he
said
well I have to address that right away
because this is scriptural first of all
so like if you don't believe the
scriptures I don't know how you ever
became a priest and then went through a
few other things and then said finished
his talk gave his talk done afterwards
he went up to the priest and said
I'm going to pray for you
in a way that you'll come to believe in
the devil
and they were all staying at this
Retreat House and that night
there were shrieks coming from that
priest's room
and when they ran to see what was wrong
and that he let them in he said the
devil came tonight
and now I believe
but praise the Lord
but it's like we're we're filming this
it's one day into lent it's the second
day of Lent right now and at Easter
we'll we'll say oh happy fault that one
for us so great So Glorious Redeemer to
celebrate even the fall of Man
because with Incarnation and atonement
actually
we're living in an even greater world
yeah and they're better scenario people
other real
thank you for coming in and thank you
for all that you do you're quite welcome
happy to be here this pleasure
see you next time